[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo
muchas son las reacciones que ha surgido
luego de que el Gobernador de Florida
Hernández santis escogiera Twitter para
hacer el anuncio oficial de sus
aspiraciones presidenciales Y aunque el
evento se vio empañado por fallas
técnicas en la plataforma la discusión
ahora se centra en el papel que ha
jugado su dueño elon musk como uno de
los protagonistas del evento Bajo su
dirección se convirtió Twitter en una
plataforma de ultraderecha lo analizamos
aquí en revista digital empezamos
hasta ahora no existían casos
documentados en los que los dueños de
las grandes redes sociales hayan apoyado
abiertamente a candidatos o
precandidatos a la presidencia de
Estados Unidos sin embargo si hablamos
de Twitter ese esfuerzo por intentar
mantener una posición neutral pareció
terminar cuando sus hijos utilizó su red
social para ayudar al gobernador de
Florida ron de santis a lanzar
oficialmente su candidatura de santis
Ultra conservador Busca ser quien
representa al partido republicano en las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 en las
que competirá con Joe biden por la Casa
Blanca Aunque más sugirió que todos los
candidatos presidenciales son
Bienvenidos a esa plataforma los medios
de comunicación estadounidenses hicieron
Eco del evento con the santis y asegura
que es de esta manera Twitter se
consolida como un medio de comunicación
conservador según la revista Atlantic
esto ya no se puede negar en este
artículo compara a Twitter con redes
sociales conservadoras como true social
de Donald Trump o Partner y dice que
ahora el sitio en sí sin duda bajo el
liderazgo de mosc en una plataforma
alternativa de redes sociales que ofrece
Un refugio a personas influyentes de
extrema derecha y promueve los intereses
los prejuicios y las teorías de
Conspiración de la derecha de la
política estadounidense la New York
magazine dice que la plataforma volverá
locos a los conservadores y que así como
Twitter ha abrazado a la derecha A la
derecha también ha abrazado a Twitter
refiriéndose a que figuras como el
presentador Tucker Carson planea emitir
un programa desde esta red social tras
ser despedido de Fox news de hecho el
portal business insider señala que
Twitter empieza a parecerse mucho a Fox
news ya que desde que asumió el cargo
elon musk ha dado la bienvenida a Los
favoritos de la cadena conservadora que
habían estado prohibidos en la
plataforma o como lo son Donald Trump y
la representante a la cámara Marjorie
Taylor Green
24 consultamos a Robert Valencia el
analista político a quien le preguntamos
si Twitter podría llegar a convertirse
en un megáfono de la extrema derecha
indudablemente le ofrece una plataforma
a al movimiento o por lo menos al
partido republicano no sabemos si hará o
extenderá la misma invitación a los
demócratas en este caso viene siendo yo
biden el Quién es el favorito para
hacerse a la candidatura demócrata pero
sí indudablemente existe ese riesgo y la
desinformación además que también se ha
dicho que
Twitter eliminó ciertas políticas además
de como ustedes ya saben removió el
digamos esta verificación azul Entonces
eso también abre el debate para abrir
cuentas falsas difundir información
falsa Así que obviamente pues Twitter se
ha convertido en esta plataforma en
donde estas estos personajes pueden
digamos
infundar sus teorías de Conspiración sin
contar también que hay muchas compañías
noticiosas como es el caso de mpr que es
la la red pública radial aquí en Estados
Unidos que optó por salir de Twitter
debido a este tipo de políticas Así que
indudablemente sí representa un grave
riesgo para aquellos a esas personas
radicales que son en su mayoría de la de
la extrema derecha Robert Valencia
también nos habló del papel que deberá
jugar Twitter de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales especialmente en los
intentos por mitigar desinformación
electoral teorías de Conspiración y
contenido falso
vamos a ver qué lecciones puede tomar
Twitter pero yo creo que no hay que
negar que elon musk tiene una afinidad
con el movimiento de la extrema derecha
o por lo menos con tendencia a la
derecha
A pesar de lo que él diga Porque él dice
que lo que está tratando de hacer es
democratizar
tuit por lo menos lo hizo mediante la el
remover las las verificaciones azules
que digo estas cuentas verificadas y
cuando hablo de cuentas verificadas
hablo de personas que están dedicadas a
la información o personas que tienen
algún tipo de interés público incluso
organizaciones etcétera Pero no
solamente estamos hablando de Twitter
como tal hay que recordar también que
está en juego el uso de la Inteligencia
artificial y yo creo que eso también va
a ser importante no solamente aunado con
el tema de Twitter y hago hincapié
específicamente en lo que hizo por
ejemplo
el comité nacional republicano
quien en respuesta a Joe biden en su en
su video oficial de lanzamiento a la
candidatura por la Casa Blanca la
respuesta que dio el comité nacional
republicano es un video utilizando
imágenes de Inteligencia artificial Pues
yo creo que igual eso abre el debate
también de la desinformación Y cómo esa
desinformación va a ser difundida
mediante medios como Twitter y no y
obviamente pues no solamente Twitter
sino también Facebook Instagram etcétera
de otro lado el evento de santis no
estuvo libre de problemas y los
internautas no lo dejaron pasar la
transmisión en Twitter Se bloqueó
repetidamente por inconvenientes
técnicos lo que generó una ola de
reacciones por ejemplo burlas al
apellido de The santis con el numeral
ron disaster que en español significa
desastre e incluso hicieron referencia
al negocio de los vuelos espaciales de
elon musk y calificaron la campaña de
santis como un cohete que falló al
despegar con estas imágenes despedimos
este capítulo de revista digital
Recuerden que si quieres repetir este u
otro episodio de nuestro programa lo
pueden hacer A través de nuestra página
web www.trans24.com
[Música]